right before Christmas a good guy in red
is coming to theaters with his new
sidekick
Fred why am I here you're in a pg-13
version of Deadpool filtered through the
prison of childlike innocence and nobody
does childlike innocence like you Fred
nobody I need you almost as much as you
need me I don't need you at all me to
untie you once we're done
[Music]
I loved your working up I'm sorry don't
get to a test one so Paul no Deadpool
character for Marvel movies we are
Merkel yeah but you're you know Marvel
license my Fox it's like if the Beatles
were produced by Nickelback it's music
but it sucks you were nicer as a kid
rated pg-13 limited engagement in
theaters December 12th
you